Hier ist Clixoom, die Online-Talkshow mit:
Kermit, dem Frosch!
Freut mich sehr!
Mich auch.
Wie ist die Lage?
Sehr gut, wir sind an diesem wundervollen Ort, es ist toll mit dir hier zu sein.
Und unser Film ist draussen, den ich sehr mag. Alles ist gut!
Du magst euren Film gern?
Er gefaellt mir sehr. Walter hat eine wichtige Rolle in diesem Film,
das ist er, der mit der Sonnenbrille.
Walter ist ein begeisteter Muppet-Fan, er kommt ganz nach Hollywood, um unser Theater zu retten. Ein wirklich netter Kerl.
Aber es ist eine lange Zeit vergangen. Unser letzter Film kam vor zwoelf Jahren raus.
Und ich muss mich erst wieder daran gewoehnen, wie es ist, auf der grossen Leinwand zu sein.
Ich muss mich da weniger und langsamer bewegen.
Denn sie ist so gross!
Und es ist ein Film mit sehr viel Musik.
Ja, so viele Songs.
Was ich an dem Film besonders mag, ist dass ich endlich wieder Rainbow Connection singen konnte. Nach all den Jahren.
Ich habe ein kleines Geheimnis fuer dich:
Nach dem Interview werden wir es zusammen singen.
Das ist wundervoll!
Ich habe sehr viel dafŸr geuebt.
Ich hab gelesen, du lebst in den Everglades?
Das stimmt. Ich lebe im Sumpf, noch immer.
Ich wohne nie in Hollywood, wenn ich gerade nicht arbeite. Ich gehe immer zurueck in den Sumpf.
Und was machst du dort den ganzen Tag?
Es ist ein sehr langsamer Lebensstil.
Ich stehe morgens auf, Strecke mich aus. Suche ein Plaetzchen und setze mich in die Sonne.
Und ich sitze einfach da. Siehst du die Reflexion in dem Piano?
Das ist wie im Sumpf.
Und ich mach einfach das hier.
Wie lang jeden Tag?
Stunden!
Ich kann damit Stunden verbringen.
Ist das nicht langweilig?
Nein, das ist sehr entspannend.
Guck dir das an! Guck!
Es ist vermutlich langweilig dabei zuzusehen. Wir sollten wohl lieber weitermachen.
Ist die ganze Arbeit an dem neuen Film nicht ungewohnt? Nach all den Jahren?
Es ist hart. Einen Film zu machen ist wirklich harte Arbeit.
Man muss Stunden in der Maske verbringen.
Wie Miss Piggy. Siehst du sie dort?
Sie verbringt 17 Stunden am Tag mit Schminken! Das laesst nur 6 Stunden zum drehen!
Harte Arbeit fuer euch.
Sehr harte Arbeit, ja.
Es ist auch anstrengend, umherzureisen und den Leuten von dem Film zu erzaehlen, aber ich rede gerne mit dir, also ist es toll.
Danke, das weiss ich zu schaetzen.
Was sind deine naechsten Projekte?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Noch reise ich um die ganze Welt und promote den Film.
Und ich hoffe, dass wir danach einen weiteren Film machen werden. Ich wuerde gerne noch einen drehen.
Ich denke, dieser Film wird ein grosser Erfolg.
Es ist der siebte Muppet-Film?
Der achte steht ausser Frage, denke ich.
Ich druecke die Daumen! Ich hoffe es wirklich.
00:03:06.0,00:03:04.0
Das tu ich auch.
Alles Gute fuer dich und deine Arbeit. Viel Erfolg und danke fuer das Interview.
Immer wieder gerne, es ist sehr nett mit dir, Christoph.